okay good morning everyone my name is
John Smith and I'm going to talk to you
about entity framework core in the
middle of 2016 I got an email out the
blue from Manning saying as a sieve you
blogged a lot about ef6 would you like
to write the book on anything look cool
out of you out the blue massive job I
really enjoyed it and I learned a lot
and then afterwards I went back to
contracting and people tended to ask me
to do very difficult things with entity
framework call because of the book so
I've had the experience of doing it in
the wild so what I tried to put together
is a whole load of different things that
don't I don't know what you know so I've
just kind of put a whole load of things
that I think are useful and possibly not
known by people and I'm hoping that
you're something that you're something
you'll go I didn't know that that's
useful right so I've got a whole
splatter of stuff can I ask how many
people are are using EF corn now most
but not all okay so I'm gonna go deep
but it's about deep about how it works
inside so if you haven't used the EF
call before you should get out some
something out of its but some of the
might go over your head but it's really
I'm just trying to tell you how it works
inside and how you can use that so I'm
going to this is my one page exploit
explaining everything about EF core well
not really the F core is an object
relational mapper and it Maps classes
you can see these are they
not very blue are they anyway that you
can see the two classes at either side
and it maps those two tables or views in
the database the database I'm going to
do a bit of demo on is really simple
you've got a set a book we've had a
one-to-one to an author and just to make
it interesting I've got four books but
the first two have the same author okay
so if you haven't come across a TF core
before it works out if core works out
what the database looks like by looking
at how you've built your class and
there's certain standard default ways of
doing it by using names but yeah there's
a load of configuration you can put in
if you want to start with a database
there's a method to reverse-engineer
that and build the classes and all the
configuration to fit okay so there you
are
you can see most of the properties are
mapped to the columns in the tables
there is one here that isn't that's
called a navigational property and a lot
of the power of EF court lives in its
navigational properties as we'll see in
a minute so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
take you into EF core and back out so we
starting at nine o'clock that's the code
and we'll go round we're doing stages so
the first thing it does when you call to
list on that with the context on the
beginning it says okay I I can
understand this you've got a property in
your context called books with me which
is mat mapped to the books table and you
want to include the author for that book
right and to this says do it for all the
whole database which is four books
translated obviously that's easy but
some are its then cashed and then it
hands over to a database provider there
are a number of database providers
sequel server sequel Lite post sequel or
post greasy cool my sequel are there
there are others you can pay for and
some other that are for don't work with
three yet which is the recent release so
the database providers job is to format
the sequel because this slight
differences between each database and
handle all the interactions with the
database and so in this case it sends
out the Select command that that your
query created and then it gets the data
and it sends it back to EF core and it
goes through three things I hope you can
see this at the back there are it
creates the classes so it creates four
books and three authors okay then it
does this thing called relational fix up
some magic here so what it says I know
I've loaded those I know all about their
priorities and foreign keys I understand
that and it then looks for any
relational navigational properties the
author one the author one I showed you
in the book and it goes oh I better fill
that in so it then makes a reference
from this book to its author and you
notice that the first two books go to
the same author and then it does
something called tracking snapshots so
it takes a copy of what's out there and
it keeps it it's kind of you can get to
it but it's inside the context you know
it's kind of hidden a bit and why is
that that so EF core is trying to
be good about doing its updates so if
you say you picked the first book and
wanted to change its title all you will
do is you you would take the first book
and you would sign a new title to the
title property and then you could call
this mega method called Save Changes and
it f qor will then look at everything
that it's tracking right and go ah
what's happened and in these in this
case it will know that it's pulled those
in they're not new and you haven't
deleted them so it goes ha better
compare these one by one against all of
these tracking snapshots and it goes to
book 1 and goes all the titles changed
go through all the ice nothing else so
at the end it says oh the only thing I
need to do is do a one line update title
for but one right and that's what it
happens now there's a couple of things
to say here one is if you're just
reading this to display to your users
you don't need this and there's a
command called as no tracking which
turns this off so it's a little bit
quicker a little less memory being used
but I need to tell you something in
before three if you had as no tracking
it would still do this for books three
authors all the links in three they
fixed well they changed as has no track
no tracking it had got some problems and
they needed to do it and they also
wanted to speed it up and that the speed
up is now it will return four books
and for authors two of them will have
duplicate data in it all right so that's
not a problem when you're going at the
front end but if you're in your business
logic and you want you to read something
in and and kind of traverse all the
relationships as no tracking rule could
change those relationships
okay so just be aware of that okay with
that's a simple I use a very simple
database to show you that let's go and
look at something a bit more complicated
so in in my book I build a super simple
Amazon site right and there's a number
of reason I picked on this we we
understand books and reviews and things
like that so it's not an alien but also
I could have Warner of each of the sort
of database type relationship so we know
a book can have multiple authors and
authors can have write multiple books so
you have to have a many-to-many the
review is you can not too many of those
that's a one-to-many and I had kind of
had to work at having a one-to-one this
is the idea is the prakit the price is
what's in there unless this is one of
those is there so yeah but anyways so
that's the database but the the the user
of my site is not really interested in
that they want to see a display and to
build that it's not trivial so the title
is easy the author the the authors there
may be multiple authors and ask to go
through the table and fill all that out
but the ones that get interesting is
working out the average I called it
votes not stars and one don't want to
Amazon coming after me by two customers
and I'm going to show you now it's in
different ways you could build that
what the performance of those are okay
so if you go to what's a loading related
data a tape page on the EF core doc site
it will list these three ways of loading
eager loading you've seen explicit
loading is I loaded the book I forgot to
load the reviews so I'll load it now
that sounds silly but you can imagine
top level someone loads a book the
business logic needs that there's a way
to get to it and then lazy loading is if
you put virtual and I think you've got
library in the what happens is if you've
got a book and you don't read this
nothing happens but if you read it it
goes ah he needs that I'll pull that in
from the database okay now there is
another way called select loading which
I use quite a lot and it allows you to
pick exactly what you want but it's
still you can still access the
relationships that are there quite
easily so you're not losing anything and
I let's the look at their timings so
select loading winds slightly over eager
loading but I want you to see this right
and it's all about trips to the database
let me yeah let me go back this is this
is three one if I go back to before
three there were more commands in here
there's a big change many of you will
know this that they've their massive
change to the the way they handle turn
link into sequel and before three if you
load in a book and then you loaded the
reviews they were done by separate
sequel commands all right so this least
who would really like this - this thing
is three in here and four in here so
there's four commands but it's all done
in one database trip and these are about
20% faster than to one but so I can say
it's not about how many commands you
don't and do it's how many trips to the
database you make is gonna hit you and I
call it every you know if this is a very
chatty this is very chatty and it not
only will hit the performance here it
will put more load on your database and
I'll talk about seeing that later so you
just gotta be aware of that and lazy
loading I get pulled in to look at
performance and lazy loading is really
easy to use and the problem is it
spreads lots of chatter across your
database sorry if but it's really easy
to use and a lot especially say you've
got a repository and you're using this
query to do in three or four places and
you now need to add reviews you don't
really want to add it to what's there it
might break something else so you use
lazy loading I understand that but
you're going to get
or database trips so let me look at the
Select loading so this is the Select
loading to build that looks horrible and
I'll break it down but it's not as bad
as you think because by the end of
running this it's done everything right
what you would have to do with the other
ones and I had to do for the test is you
had to pull in all the the reviews then
you had to get count them then you have
to do the average then you had to check
whether there was a promotion and all
that sort of stuff it's all done in here
the benefits of this you will see in a
minute but I want to oh yeah so you
noticed this I just want to focus on
this bit if I put in reviews reviews.com
EF core goes I can do that in sequel
right so it never has to load the
reviews this one getting the average
that that was really hard to work out I
had to ask
get the team on github you have to put a
double nullable double double there and
why is that it turns out it's because
the average of most of the aggregate
commands in the database like some
average max min if there's no data they
turn return now all right so you have to
make it you have to have a double
because this is a this is a byte and and
that won't average with it so but that's
why you need another book and before
three if you got it wrong it would do it
but it would do it all in in them it
would pull stuff in MA
to pull times into the software and do
it there and it was terrible performance
right and I know about that it really
aren't early on in the book and and I
just warned people about that but I
think the team must have seen that
there's just terrible performance so in
three if you do if you didn't put that
in you'd get I can't handle this all
right it'll just kick it out so I think
that's better but I man I would imagine
anybody that's converted from two to
three might have had a few queries that
broke I don't know anybody hmm anyway my
client did that's why he hired me so
anyway if you do this again that average
will be done in your database so I'm
gonna say don't don't try and read that
I'm going to give you a bigger science
but I just want to say that EF core that
this is taken from a information logging
from Air Corps and if you're using
normal deficit system it will appear for
you and it rot it produces really
readable sequel now I know you're using
EF core because you don't want to go
anywhere see near sequel right but when
it comes to performance sometimes it's
good to be able to look at that now I
tried the same thing on EF six and it
was a hundred mmm-mmm-mmm 218 lines and
it was completely impenetrable it was
you couldn't read it this you could pick
up you'd have to replace that with a an
ID and run it somewhere and just see
what's going on so I'm just saying it's
you most likely don't want to go near
sequel but when you perform and starts
kicking in this is what you can do I
just want to look at this this is the
account and this is the
of doing the average in the database so
I I didn't I didn't want to skew things
if I were put in a hundred I only had
ten reviews to average and count if I'd
put him more the timings will be more
apart but this is a very special thing
so I'm not trying to say that you know
select is always going to be way better
anything than anything else this is a
particular case but what what I would
say is in this book there's a
description and normally that would be
very big and if you were using include
or anything else it would load that and
you don't need it in a select load you
can leave that out again in the test I
did the the description was like ten
characters so it didn't really have make
any difference the only problem is
select loading is that they're hard to
write so I just want to point out a bit
most of you know about Auto mapper right
it's a been around for years and it's a
object to object mapper so it'll map
things from one class to another class
but it will also produce link so there's
a command project to which instead of
copying things it will create the link
that will do the copy right and so for
instance if this is my I got a dto view
model whatever it's just as the thing
that I want to go to if you put author
name and there's something called author
and something and it's got a property
called name Auto mapper will
automatically work out that they same
with poke post count for this
complicated thing you'd have to tell it
directly what it to do but Auto mapper I
use a lot
it's a really good library it's well
supported I think the doc you made
documentation is quite hard work but
anyway that that will help you if you
want to use select queries okay so we've
read Reds things from the database so
now we're going to talk about pushing
things out to the database and in my
book I've got my one-to-one my
one-to-many and my many-to-many
relationships and I've decided I want to
create a new book with an existing order
or author okay so this is one way of
doing it you create the book you save it
you get the primary key and you fill in
the this this linking table has to have
these foreign keys filled in okay so
that's one way to do it the problem I
don't mind
setting up relationships with by setting
foreign keys but I do have a problem
with to save changes so the problem with
that is that you've got a book that is
incomplete hasn't got an author right
you save it and then you something goes
wrong here and this doesn't happen at
that point you've got a book which might
break your system right so you want to
you don't want to do have to save
cheney's like that so in my systems I
get everything ready and I call once I
save change and just for people that
don't know save changes does all this
kind of clever stuff but then anything
it saves it saves within transaction so
either it all works or none of it works
right so if you can't do it that way how
can you do it
well these
occasional properties so here is another
version and you may not realize but here
we're doing something to the author link
that's a navigational property when it
when it goes and look this all that's
changed and it will say alright I'm
always a new book author right that's
not in the database all wipe I better
add that too and then in the book author
I said I just set the author this is the
navigational property with the author
that I've loaded and then I can call
Save Changes just once so let me let's
go through this because it's interesting
what Pao TF court does that so the red
things are new the blue thing is they're
already so I've run all my code but I
haven't called add all say chains so I
the links in there you can see that
there's no primary key in here and
there's no foreign keys in there when
you call add it does a couple of things
I don't know what order but it fills in
any foreign keys and needed it it knows
from the links what you want and it
fills in the foreign key so the this one
was easy it's at all I'm not linked to
that o is it's already got key right
okay I'll fit it in when it comes to
this one it goes on no I've got that yet
so it fills it with a both the book ID
primary key in the book and the foreign
key in the book author with a the same
large negative number before I go on EF
call change call three change before
three it did put it in the properties in
your classes now it puts it in the
snap tracking snapshot there's reason
for that but anyway so the you wouldn't
see that after you'd done ad it would be
hidden and then where you go Save
Changes
it works out which order to write things
out and sets it out I'm going to show
you the sequel for that in a minute
and then what it does when it's done all
that it it will copy any changes that
happened in the database back into your
classes so that they are an exact
correct against the database and it and
they go to the state of under unchanged
IC show you this equal so it puts the
book out this command gets the primary
key and then uses it to create the book
author that's a very simple example I
had a multinational client who had got
two security systems the new one and an
existing one and they wanted to link
them and we came up they didn't really
want to touch the existing security
system so I built a an application I did
reverse engineered the main the the
existing database so I could access it
right and the new system would send me
events and I've had to build really
complex set of things pulling that from
that database that delete in there
adding that and there were about 15
classes and I changed relationships I
changed I added things new classes to it
I removed classes from it I changed
things and then even the the project
manager who is a quite techie said don't
you have to write them in the right
order I said no you have call do that so
I just tend all this mess back
to f qor and it works out everything and
it does it in the right order put it in
the right place and it just works and
that for me is is fantastic I'm going to
talk very briefly about domain driven
design domain driven design talks about
when you're doing your business logic
your your business logic should not
really know anything about the database
and because of the way EF core works it
can do that you can use all these
navigational links and never touch
priorities foreign keys never look at
them and your data that your business
logic can work as if it's just an
in-memory set of classes there's a few
little things that you have to give it
to help hit I agree if you add something
you you know that over it or delete
something there's some things you need
to do but in general it makes your
business logic really easy to work on
okay okay let's keep going so I just
wanted to come back to this because
there's something going on that is I
think it's quite interesting so we know
we've seen this right at the beginning
if you did that they're all linked up
nicely but did you know if you loaded
the books and then loaded the authors
they'd also end up linked so you have to
understand that that when you when you
load anything so this is it licit say
this is the first thing and now it's
tracking those books right then you the
next thing you load it will look at
everything that is tracking and it will
say should I be linked to this and then
it will fill in those links so it's
amazing you know you can pull this in
and pull that in and it'll go all
it'll link it all up right now I was
putting this talk together over
Christmas and I'm working for a client
at the moment and we had just we know we
had a problem with showing a job I won't
go into the details but and with it
they've got a big but not the biggest
job and it took nine seconds to display
that's not going to be good right and it
was it was all about hierarchical data I
seem to do a lot with hierarchical data
and hierarchical data is really hard to
performance-tuned and I've got a method
where I I pulled in the first three with
by going Parowan include chai or
children then include children and then
I had to do down here I did explicit
loads so it's very chatty and I thought
I'm done saying all this thing about the
cleverness of the link of relational
fix-up can I get that to work for me and
yes I can so if I I all these blue
things have a job ID if I load them just
with one child all these relationships
are set up you know I just get them all
in I have to find the parent by saying
you know it's not there's no its parent
ID is now yeah but it fills it all in so
that radically changes my software we
did quite a lot of other things as well
I'm not saying only this but by doing
that I really reduced loads of database
access accesses to three really big
accesses that pull things in and a small
one I couldn't avoid and the whole thing
went down from nine to under
two seconds and the problem is not this
now it's that the problem always was
with to put this information on the
display we needed this but there were
about six other very big queries going
on as well all in parallel and the
chattiness of that was you know there's
so much hitting that database
it was slowing everything down so this
took a lot of the chattiness out and now
the problem is still the other ones are
a bit chatty right and we can but we're
in a good place now so we're happy so
yeah it's it's ticks tricks like this
that can help you make your systems run
better right I'm gonna do domain-driven
design in five minutes impossible I came
across a domain driven design in 2012
and I I've had a really interesting
career I was a developer I was the
manager of developers and take the
director and everything and I came back
to programming and this book just spoke
to me because I'm used to talking to
customers and developers and writing
code and I love it but I would say it's
taken me quite some time to get a feel
for the right ways to do it so I
recommend it and do get into it but it's
you know you're gonna pick where you
start I all I want to cover is that the
if you want to make your classes at your
EF core classes a follow the standard
that DDD's talks about which is all the
properties and all the collections
should be read only you should have a
the public constructor should have you
know you it would only create a valid
book you know it have title price Buddha
and authors so the idea is you can never
create something in here that is invalid
it's and it's it's a job of this class
to keep it valid and so in if you want
to change anything you have to go
through veteran methods to change things
because then the class can always keep
itself valid all I want to talk about is
how you could make a class lock down the
class so that you could do DD so of
course you can set the the private
setters there what should stop you know
anybody accessing any of those but when
it came to the collections if you had a
collection you can still add or remove
from it and the way around it is by
using backing fields anybody who's using
backing fields either I'll use them a
lot they're really good so what backing
field says is and this is an EF call
thing you've got a field here private
field and it will read and write to that
in EF core 3 that is the default setting
before before 3 it wasn't but now it is
and that's the the best thing to do so
it reads and writes to that and then you
give something to the if someone look
needs to get to the reviews you you give
it something which it can't change this
is the recommended way by Arthur Vickers
who's the top man EF Corps you put an
iron innumerable
so you can't add and remove from that
and you also take a copy of the review
is to send back so even if you cast it
you can't get back to the data right and
then you have an ad review command and
you can have a remove review and update
review and all sorts of things in there
all I wanted or two to talk to you about
is about how you would set up your class
to be DDD I that's all I can do in this
time try okay I've just this is the kind
of things I've come across that you you
might know about some of them but I
think they useful so there is a thing
called global query filters which you
can use in a couple of ways I've built a
big multi-tenant system for a company
and the quick I use query filters to
separate off so a multi-tenant system is
like github or something like that so
each company logs in and they have their
own slice of that data and you can use
query filters to do that really really
well right and it and the idea is they
can only access their data and they
can't see anything else and query
filters are brilliant for that the other
thing that all my users have done is
implemented soft delete this is like you
you want to give a delete command to
your users but when they come back to
say I deleted something it I want it
back you want a way to get it back and
this is what soft delete using a query
filter with something like this that
says if that is true it won't show the
book so here's a little super simple
unit test load for books
sets off delete true Save Changes count
is now three if I say ignore query
filters it's full so that book has
disappeared and I can tell you because
I'm worried about this and I checked it
all you can't get in a query you can't
get it with a find you can't get with an
include I don't know anyway other than
going to sequel you can make that appear
all or this command right to make it
appear right so it's really good so it's
gone from the users right but then when
they come as a I'll please to help me
you know Oh work for hours doing this
set the Bing back it reappears it's
lovely and all my clients have done that
the thing I want to talk about though
and we're having a philosophical
discussion with my client if you if you
deleted this book for real the reviews
would be deleted as well it's a cascade
delete because the reviews rely on that
book and they would delete right if you
soft delete that the review still remain
you haven't soft deleted the reviews so
you've got to be a little bit careful
about how you access things off the book
there's a thing in domain room driven
design about called root and aggregate
and what they say is this is a root and
the the the reviews are is a nagger it
underneath and it says you should always
go through the root two to access the
aggregate so if you always try to get
the reviews by pulling the book in and
then getting the reviews off that you'll
be fine because you will never get that
book yeah so just bear that in mind
okay let's keep going on value
converters so these came in in two one
it's not a new thing in three but I
really like these so if the problem I
had if I save a date time to the
database and then I pull it back out
again it's lost its it's kind it if it
was UTC it doesn't say it's UTC anymore
and that's a problem if I'm sending JSON
to my front end because it hasn't got
the Zed in it and that that was a before
this I had to I did it with back in
fields and stuff
but now you could have this conversion
so this is what you can convert things
when it goes out and when it comes back
in so when it goes out I just sent it
out but when it comes back I add the UC
T back and that is magic another thing
that the my current client does he's
quite sequel centric in he understand
you know he does a lot of things down
there so he stayed saves his enums and
strings because the normally saved as
numbers and if you know working out it's
number seven it is you know blow up or
something you know it's so and what this
does is it send it makes it a string in
the database when it comes back that
turns it back into a ena that's that's
really nice so what's the next one oh
yes I'm always looking for ways to
automate things and my current client I
got pulled in quite late he's got a
massive he's put all his configuration
in his DB context and it's really long
and there is a way to automate some of
your setting up and configuration so so
here we are this is the way to do it it
model Biddle model builder model you
have to
use that one not the one in dbcontext
get enter he type that returns like a
bit of stuff about the that class with
some stuff omit from EF cool then I can
get all the properties you can you can
see where I'm going here don't you
so if it's a date/time and it ends with
UTC make it usually UTC I have a lot of
things saying you know created at UTC
updated at UTC I've got loads of them
and this will just pick all of them up
there are a number of ways you can do
that that's one of them unfortunately
for the soft early it's not so simple
you you can't there isn't it kind way
you can do it you have to create
dynamically create a little config class
of the right type and this guy on
stackoverflow filter all curries trying
to achieve soft delete have done it and
he's got a little bit of code which you
can you can see I'm going to the same
same going through them or if it's got a
nice soft delete type on it then set
doesn't the query filters that is
quicker and more secure right you don't
want to have a soft delete that hasn't
got been set properly so that is a good
approach cosmos DB this is a bit of code
from a cosmos TV test I did in my book I
started with 50 books at the beginning
in chapter 13 I went up to a hundred
thousand books and a half a million
reviews and guess what the sequel was
slow
if because it's doing a lot of work and
I perform is doing that and then in
chapter 14 I built this this is a CQRS
pattern
I had a sequel database and I had a no
sequel bait database where you you
worked out all the data put it on there
and it comes out kind of already
pre-baked I I rebuilt this with cosmos
DB and it's lovely
right and the idea is to you know I in
my book I'm in a half a million books
with Raven DB and it was just it was
just yes fine you know it's like it's
fine isn't it was really really really
fast
and this I haven't totally timed it
because I've got a whole love a whole
other set of stuff that I'm doing along
with it but it's looking like it will be
just as quick so in doing that I spent a
lot of time looking at cosmos DB in EF
call three and if you go to my site is a
if if you go to my site and then go to
no sequel as you know one of the
categories you'll find this and I found
all sorts of interesting things about
about cosmos DB and about EF cause setup
for instance counting the number of
books is a very costly thing with cosmos
DV you don't want to do it right and
there are some things that were broke
broken in in EF call and some
limitations that they haven't dealt with
yet I think it's cosmos DB is fine but
one of the things you can't at the
moment you can I can have a cosmos DB
and I can put in the reviews inside that
but what I can't do is have a cosmos DB
a cosmos book and a cosmos reviews and
have a relation between them and they
and they say it's going to change but it
doesn't look like it's going to change
in five so I don't know what's going on
but so it cosmos TVs is there it's it's
good but there are some limitation like
they haven't done all the aggregates so
you can't do the anchor it so it can't
count
you can't some things like that there's
you know this thing's there so just be
be aware of that okay oh oh right yes
side I I do
unit test my code using real database
and a lot of people say no let's do that
thought you should mock it out and all
that sort of doesn't so that's fine but
when you went when you go from version
two to version 3 of EF core my client
had a lot of things broken and they
because he didn't unit test them I had
because I knew of this problem really
early on it was all about client versus
server and all that sort of stuff
I built a library and I checked I
checked that so all my code worked went
to three fine but my client you know it
was there were lots of places where it
couldn't translate it if he'd unit
tested those code then he would have
found that so what I'm saying is people
say oh you you don't need to test a of
core no you don't but you do need to
test your use of EF core and I make lots
of mistakes right
I love unit tests right and so I I test
it so how can you do it well so the
first thing if you're loop using really
Stan
the EF core you're not using any special
things in your database you're not using
user-defined functions or computed
columns and things like that you can use
a sequel in-memory database and it's
it's very quick and it's empty when you
get it and it's just for this test all
right so it's really good so if you can
if if you're working that way if you're
doing something new in the database that
is more complicated you can't use this
because it just won't work
but I use sequel Lite because it checks
all my references if I it'll tell me if
I you know if I do something wrong with
some because it's it's taking checking
the room the the integrity of the
database and so I have a library and
I've just that the code in the last Tet
the the last slide was what I've got and
what the other thing that helps you is
that EF core has this command context
database in ensure creating it's meant
for unit tests and what it says nothing
about migration just says what are your
class you've got looking like now what
should the debate I'll make a database
exactly the right like that right so
it's going to be exactly what you have
at the moment and then you could and
it's empty so you can you know do stuff
whatever right so that's really that's
really good and I recommend it if you
don't it gets a bit more complicated so
you have to this is in my library I
create a unique unique database name off
the class I give
class so because let's not talk about
the my code let's talk about the problem
if you're running unique unit tests I'm
using X unit which most people my ear of
call use it it runs all your unit tests
in parallel or it can run all this you
yeah so if if you you can't have one
database being used by all your unit
test so this one made makes it unique to
the class you I've also got one for
making it unique to a method but all I'm
doing is changing the name of the of the
database and then you have the problem
that the database may have been used
before so it's got data in it so you're
gonna got to deal with it I've got one
way of doing it there are the definitive
way to do is delete the database and
recreate it but it takes about 8 or 10
seconds and that slows down you know
you're all your unit tests and I don't
like that so I try to work and do things
to get round that okay and we're nearly
there are we doing here good I'm
thinking of this is the end right way
I'm thinking of writing some articles
around the things I've put in this in
this talk and I would like your advice
on what you thought was good bad you
know what didn't understand whatever and
I'll I'll try and then do it I'm I'm
working you know contractor so it won't
come out like like that but you know I'd
like like to talk about that and I've
got six minutes for any questions sir
um okay most people work mostly hmm it
depends for me I I use code first and I
have a a I've built something in my
Tessa port which will matter with which
will compare the the classes that what
the what EF Corps thinks that the
classes look like from the config and
the database so it will tell me how they
differ and then I build scripts to
update the database I don't use
migrations but I'm a bit you know nerdy
and I I'm gonna do that night you know
so I don't use migrations my current
client uses migrations
I'll talk to you after this because I've
got a big two blogs on my do migrations
and all that sort of stuff anybody else
oh no it's best with best for simplicity
yes so all my unit tests I try not to
use a sink because I don't mind in my
unit tests and debugging acing is a
little bit more harder but of course
I'll have method in there but in in the
main stuff I I use acing a lot I don't
use it absolutely everywhere there are
some places where a really small query
is quicker sink so if you're loading a
very small thing using the primary key
then I might I might use sink right oh
and another techie thing I only learn
this I thought find is the right way to
load an entity it's okay but single or
default off a primary key is twice as
fast all right
so worth knowing that and it's because
the the find is looking in the local
dbcontext I think so it's a bit slower
so
what like you wait for doing bulk
updates or delete a lot yeah big list of
deletes or updates yeah I wouldn't say
that
EF core is great for big updates if
you've got just one thing with no
relationships which I never have and
normally saving great chunks of things
then there are libraries that will do
that much quicker right EF core is
better than EF six it a bulk load
[Music]
undelete I'm I haven't time delete - I
think deletes aren't too bad Oh have you
found that or just generated or just the
primary keys yeah so you you can delete
things just by creating a the entity
with just the primary key you should go
to get around anyway I think one more
minute sir
yeah and so in in my book so going to
dapper right absolutely fine fine EF
core is good but it's not perfect so you
know you use the EF core because it's
quick to build right and then when you
get a problem you you decide what you're
going to do and and going to dapper
could be a very good decision what I
would say I've found that for big at the
queries that do a lot
dapper is not that faster unless you've
got some better sequel to put in there
because that was really quick because it
it you know because it it's so small but
when the all the time is tiny in the
database it doesn't make much different
yeah anyway I think that's it thank you
very much
[Applause]